oh mama we gotta talk hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're gonna be looking at
lifestyle youtuber and mama aspen over
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a big trigger warning to those
with current and previous experiences
with disordered eating as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are new here welcome lovelies please do
not hesitate to click that button to
subscribe and ring that bell so that you
never miss out on an episode and also a
reminder that i filmed these way in
advance so it's possible that aspen's
actually had her new baby since this
video which i assume will also change
her diet pattern a little bit as well in
this video that we're going to be taking
a look at she is pregnant with her
second babe and also is showing what
she's feeding her daughter cove let's
take a look and i was gonna make it like
all vegan but she wants to eat eggs for
breakfast and i also don't want to film
her because she doesn't have a shirt on
lots to love here first of all i do
appreciate that she's not showing her
daughter naked on her channel there are
lots of reasons why i personally don't
show my kids in my content but at the
top of the list is to help maintain
their safety and dignity now i also
appreciate that she doesn't want to like
fake these wedding a day videos for the
sake of like an seo friendly video title
so while she's going to be sharing some
vegan recipes for inspiration her family
is going to continue to eat some
non-plant-based options and if that's
what's working for her family i think
that's really great let's see what she's
having should i put yours in your own
bowl or do you want to just share with
mom
for this oatmeal i have my peach
cinnamon this is vegan whipped cream
that's so good i also like to put honey
on it this is what it looks like that
looks so delicious and i also love the
idea of a little whipped cream action to
elevate a simple weekday meal
now i know she's trying to do like a
vegan day but if she wasn't i would
suggest trying to bump up the protein a
bit in there so maybe enjoying her
daughter's eggs with her or you know
whipping some egg whites into the
oatmeal to make my famous protest and i
actually have a new vegan version of my
protest as well with silken tofu that
would also help to bump up the satiety
factor as well and then if we just
topped it all off with like some healthy
fats hemp hearts walnuts flax chia
something like that we would get the
benefit of better satiety for her and
some brain boosting omega-3s for a babe
but it looks great and usually give her
an option of what to eat like she can
have what mom's eating or my dad's
eating like breakfast is always just
super easy and then dinner if we're like
making a big meal she just eats what we
eat i am all about encouraging our
littles to eat our family meals not only
because it's logistically way easier but
also because it helps encourage our kids
to try new things and not to hold out
for the familiar kid food option all
foods can be kid foods assuming they're
developmentally appropriate for them to
eat but i always just recommend ensuring
that there's at least one to two
familiar or safe foods on the table that
we know our kiddo likes so that they can
feel safe that there's something that
they can feel their bellies with if
maybe they're not so up to trying
something new so for more information on
this method of feeding which we call the
division of responsibility you can check
out my video on it right here this is
what i have today i have a couple
different prenatal ones but i'm going to
take these gummies today this is what i
have for her
multivitamin i want to give her like a
gummy or something so i feel like she
would like it okay so i'm glad she's
taking of course her prenatal very
important now gummy vitamins are very
popular for prenatals for moms to be who
are maybe having a hard time swallowing
traditional capsules but as i discussed
in my video on the best and worst
multivitamins right here gummies are
notoriously ranked pretty poorly for
quality when tested so gummies like this
one a day also don't contain any iron
because they ruin that kind of sweet
gummy flavor so if iron is important to
you or you're having a hard time getting
in your diet as a mom to be then that's
definitely something to consider also
while this brand does have a nice range
of nutrients most of them are not in the
best bioavailable form i'd also ideally
want to choose a prenatal with some more
dha omega-3s in it since there's a lot
of important evidence on the benefits of
dha for baby's brain so research
actually suggests that babies born to
moms with higher dha omega-3 levels are
actually significantly ahead of their
peers in some ways developmentally even
years down the road so this to me is
just such an easy investment that we can
make during those important pregnancy
months as for her daughter's malte i
don't think it's a bad idea to give
children a multivitamin for like peace
of mind but i would say that iron
supplements can be pretty hard on their
little tummies and kids coves age
actually only need seven milligrams of
iron per day which really isn't that
hard to get through food so unless
there's an indication that your kiddo is
iron deficient i would personally avoid
a multivitamin with iron i actually have
a whole blog post on food sources of
irons for toddlers and babies that i'm
gonna leave below but really great
sources include things like eggs meat
beans tofu potatoes and things like
dried apricots for lunch for me i'm
gonna make a
salad my mom showed me the salad i think
it's like from instagram or something i
don't know usually i like to use the
bagged kale that's already chopped up i
also need sunflower seeds and hemp seeds
and then white beans put in some kale
these are the sunflower seeds i just
like sprinkle some in same for the hemp
seeds and then for the beans i also
don't like specifically measure these
and then for the dressing i'm gonna do a
little bit of olive oil i have dijon
mustard so a little bit of that then
just like a squirt of maple syrup like
that much salt sure there's a life hack
that you can like microwave lemons and
then you get more juice out of them
and mix it all up started making coves
lunch and then she came in and was super
sad i have this falafel from trader
joe's and she also loves corn so i try
to do some type of like protein or
something and then a veggie and usually
a fruit so i was gonna do blueberries
for her or
i have some watermelon cut up so i'm
going to have salad and watermelon taste
test
okay this salad looks incredible and
definitely nutrient dense for a mama to
be so we've got lots of fiber in there
from the beans falafel greens and seeds
we got fat in the seeds and oil a little
carbs in the melon and some protein in
the beans and falafel it's definitely a
lighter meal but there is a good amount
of nutrient dense additions in that
salad so i would think it's pretty
satisfying if you're only hungry for
something light as for cove's lunch this
is basically how we roll in my house too
so especially if i'm having some like a
salad my kids will get like all the
salad components so basically i aim for
some source of protein and iron some
kind of higher calorie higher fat food
like cheese avocado nut butter toast and
like that some kind of vegetable and or
fruit and a favorite carb and then for e
i always add something sweet on his
plate like a small cookie to really help
to neutralize the concept of dessert
basically all foods are equal mama is
gonna make a smoothie with you we're
gonna make a little chocolate protein
shake we have frozen bananas and then i
have chocolate protein powder next we
have spinach so super easy bananas
protein powder almond milk and spinach
yay i got you a cup too
this is coco's afternoon snack she's got
her green smoothie she loves carrots she
has some hummus a couple chips some
beans some blueberries and then i just
stuck some spinach on there just for the
heck of it even though obviously she is
not liking it okay this looks like a
great balanced smoothie so we've got
carbs in the banana we got protein the
protein powder plus some veggie action
in the spinach now of course if this
were to be a meal i would definitely say
we'd want to bump up the fat there so
maybe throw some nut butter or seeds in
there but i would say that this is a
pretty great snack to carry us between
meals now having said that as discussed
in my video on protein powder here i
don't usually recommend protein powder
for pregnant moms to be and definitely
not for kids because of the risk of
heavy metal contamination
i also couldn't find any information on
simple truths website about third-party
testing procedures now i don't want to
be an alarmist oh my god okay it's
happening everybody stay calm and i
don't think that this product is
necessarily dangerous but i would just
avoid supplements like these moving
forth to be safe but the rest of cove's
snack platter looks fantastic even
without the smoothie so i would
personally stick to that for the whole
family if possible i also want to say
that i think it's a smart move to just
put the spinach there on the snack
platter even if you know aspen knows
that cove isn't necessarily going to
like it or eat it because that is going
to count as an exposure and the more
exposures our kids have to naturally
nourishing foods the more likely they
are to try them and eventually eat them
and eventually like them in the future
nutrition with kids is really a long
game all right so it is time for dinner
it's 5 45 and tonight we are having
veggie bowls it's pretty easy especially
because parker just like microwaved the
rice and the sweet potato so we have a
microwave rice you just roast whatever
veggies so we have broccoli corn and
chickpeas we have this tahini dressing
so good coco has the same thing parker's
gonna have the same thing but with
chicken
okay is there anything cuter than
watching a tyler eat with like a little
baby fork or spoon
i just love it what a sweet kid um but
also this looks incredible so we've got
protein in the chickpeas and carbs and
the sweet potatoes and the tahini and
some extra veggies with the broccoli
it's also a perfect toddler meal as well
and i love the banana on the side as
that familiar sweet toddler approved
safe food so great job mama i don't
usually have tea but this is raspberry
leaf tea which is supposed to maybe help
you with labor i forget what it even
does i drink it with cove and i had a
really good labor with her i don't know
if it actually does anything but you
know might as well try uh yes
raspberry leaf tea uh it doesn't taste
like raspberries just in case you're
curious i personally think it tastes
like steeped foliage but alas you know
you do often see it recommended in late
pregnancy to help tone the uterus as a
natural form of labor induction now we
actually have four pretty comprehensive
review articles on the topic and all
four found insufficient evidence for its
use in pregnancy one old randomized
control trial found no significant
differences between moms given the
raspberry leaf supplement or a placebo
on really any outcome including length
of pregnancy need for medical
intervention or maternal health outcomes
there also didn't seem to be a
significant difference in side effects
though so i mean if you like the taste
of it and you want to give it a go then
i really don't think it seems to do any
harm if i'm being honest i was so
desperate to avoid an induction when i
was pregnant with baby e i drink a ton
of this stuff and
well
i had to two back-to-back inductions
anyway but alas i do hope that it works
better for her as for the snack i love
me a good summer peach but if she wants
to make her bedtime snack a little more
satisfying she could do one peach and
like a handful of pistachios or serving
some chia pudding with the peach but on
that note let's get to the stats so on
this day aspen is consuming just over 2
100 calories with 68 from carbs 14 from
fat and 18 from protein she's also
getting around 53 grams of fiber which
is gonna hopefully help her during
pregnancy since one of the most common
pregnancy complaints is constipation and
hemorrhoids as baby starts to kind of
anatomically shift things around down
there now otherwise my only suggestion
would be to focus on that dha omega-3
which is i know more challenging to get
on a vegan diet outside of an
algae-based supplement and her prenatal
only had a very small amount so it might
just be worth looking for a prenatal
that has a little bit more now let's get
into my general thoughts on aspen's diet
so generally speaking it was an absolute
pleasure watching aspen and her sweet
little family as she prepares for baby
number two aspen just seems to prefer to
eat predominantly plant-based which is
reflected in her meal choices in this
day and also in other what i eat in a
day videos on her channel but her meals
are never accompanied by any demonizing
or moralizing language nor did i hear
any pseudoscience explanation for her
meals or ingredients that she chooses to
eat i mean even with the red raspberry
leaf tea she was like hey i have no idea
why this works or if it works i'm just
gonna give it a try and it is also
commonly recommended by even some
doctors and midwives even if the
research is disappointingly meh so i
don't think she's in the wrong for
wanting to give that a go i also did
because i would have done anything to
try to make labor a little bit less
laborious so while i appreciate the
flexibility i want to just clarify that
i don't think that raising an
exclusively plant-based family is an
issue either if that's what she decides
that she eventually wanted to do it's
absolutely possible to raise a
plant-based or predominantly plant-based
toddler with the right planning and
structure in place but i am just happy
to hear morally neutral language when
discussing animal products especially in
the presence of her daughter cove
calling out certain ingredients as bad
or junk as we've seen others do in front
of or directly to their kids
that may set up our children for a
complicated relationship with food so i
think aspen's doing a really great job
modeling a neutral relationship with
food to her daughter and if you're
looking for some more guidance on this
yourself you can definitely check out my
video on raising an intuitive eater
right here vegan or not i would say her
meals are generally really well balanced
and nutrient dense and likely
calorically adequate for a woman her
size honestly it is just such a relief
to see an influencer not trying to live
on a diet under 1500 calories especially
when growing another human if i had any
advice it would maybe just be a little
bit more mindful of the supplements
she's choosing both for herself while
pregnant and also for cove so speaking
to a registered dietitian about what
she's using or serving her kids will
help ensure that her supplement regimen
is both effective and also safe
also i don't want her to freak out
thinking that what she's been consuming
or done is dangerous for her baby or for
her or for cove i just think that if we
want to exercise extreme caution that we
may want to back off on some of those
supplements i just don't think that the
benefit is worth any potential risk
finally i also have to applaud aspen for
involving her daughter in meal prep and
encouraging her to enjoy the same meals
as the rest of the family listen i know
that kids can be picky and sometimes it
can be really disheartening to see a
meal that you've spent time and money
preparing just like chucked on the floor
every single night but raising healthy
competent eaters is really a long game
with our kids and consistently short
order cooking to our kids demands just
communicates to them that foods for
adults are categorically different than
foods for kids so you know there's like
no incentive to try anything novel or
new so i think aspen's method of serving
deconstructed components of her meals
for her toddler while ensuring that
there is still a safe generally accepted
option for her is definitely really
smart and it will probably also save her
sanity when she's got like a second at
the table and her bandwidth for meal
prep is stretched even more thin in
conclusion it's possible aspen has
already had her baby by the time that
this video goes live and if so i hope
that she's soaking in all of those sweet
fresh newborn vibes while eating all the
things
so good luck mama on life as a mom of
two and on that note that is all that i
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to review next subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]